you know you're doing jumping jacks and
your knees don't hurt no more
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
we're here at the new offices the new
church facilities we will unveil it to
you by wednesday once we hang the
american flag up the microphones coming
in we're going back to [ __ ] basics
you understand me we're going back to
the [ __ ] what do you call a little
hole when the bottom [ __ ] comes and
where people hide we're going down the
shelter we're going to the bomb shelter
you understand
there because that's what we're going to
go and just hang and sit and [ __ ]
smoke dope what's with the questions got
a second i've never heard anyone say
let's go to the bombshell let's go to
the [ __ ] that's what this is
the last the last place is the last
chance there's a [ __ ] bombshell
[ __ ] there's air conditioning windows
humanity we've got black people we got
russian [ __ ] black male got russians
guarding the [ __ ] thing you know what
i'm saying i don't mind black people
that lady was just confused black person
that's it
she was trying to be somebody who's
she's not which is
[ __ ]
62 percent of this [ __ ] la scene and
40 everywhere else he's a [ __ ] black
woman trying to be a notary republican i
can't say she can't be in the republic
but she was sitting this [ __ ] cubicle
all day doing dick just i you know it
was one of those places where she went
just to hang out to tell somebody she
had a [ __ ] office that that there's
no office you don't invite nobody there
yeah but what are you [ __ ] we got a
better place [ __ ] it we got a better
place right up here we're crossing the
[ __ ] car lot we got in and out burger
down the corner oh that could be bad we
got a chinese joint on the building we
got a cvs joint down the corner before i
started going to china delhi used to go
that joint up the corner oh [ __ ] got a
nice lunch special not too [ __ ] bad
what made you leave
i found the better giant but then they
all suck dick now so i don't need
chinese food at all
for your mother for mother's day oh yeah
very important we only have one [ __ ]
mother when she's gone
you can't get nothing back you know oh
my god
i'm sure everyone not everyone saw it
but sportscenter like they'll usually do
one story that will make you cry they
had like a 10 minute segment of like
five or six stories of these moms that
were in the army or the navy and coming
back to surprise their kids oh it's
[ __ ] tough it's very tough i can't my
cousin is in the air force and she just
went to she's in afghanistan for six
months and she has like a two-year-old
kid
but luckily she went to the to live with
the dad for the six months but it's just
it's crazy
it's very crazy to uh give up your
children and go but that's a commitment
you make you know when it
makes you stronger it makes you tougher
in a way
i just want to give a shout out to the
mothers that listen to the show without
you we got [ __ ] nothing
it all starts with that [ __ ] monkey
that's the bottom line it all starts
there and uh
so i hope all the guys and girls that
listen to the church gave your mom's
love because at the end
you got nothing i don't have a mom to
send the [ __ ] card to i don't have
somebody to send flowers to her to call
and
tell her thank you for [ __ ] giving me
a chance but in my heart i do i have a
lot of moms so i called them all
yesterday and i
had a nice time with my wife you know
were going to go i [ __ ] the night
before first off santa fe was tremendous
awesome santa fe is a great little city
new mexico is one of the uncharted
[ __ ] you know nobody thinks in new
mexico nobody
i was introduced to new mexico maybe 15
years ago okay when i was when i was in
college and i was getting ready to go to
prison i worked for the hertz
corporation i was part of the management
training management training program and
i'd have to drive cars
on the weekends that was my job to back
to their original destination
so i they offered it to me some kid
could do it for eight bucks an hour i
could do it for like 15 and a hotel and
[ __ ] that sounds awesome and i didn't
do comedy then it just used to get me
out of town to breathe and think about
my life and where i was going to go i
take a couple j's and
no coke on those trips and i just spend
the weekend and i got to eat the green
chilies and i got to learn about their
culture and it's really a neat [ __ ]
place uh it's it's [ __ ] beautiful
new mexico as a whole is beautiful
that's a great jackson's camping and i
wish they could have came to the uh
show but they had their own fights in
albuquerque we shot the longest yard in
santa fe
and that was the first time i was back
in santa fe since the longest yard so
the first day we got there we went
outside ari and i am well are we going
to get high i got one more week before i
could get high till saturday and i'm
smoking reefers how long would it have
been 90 days on saturday wow we'll talk
about that later it's so funny i sat
outside and uh
this vet came up to us this great kid
from las cruces anthony and his
girlfriend
and they asked if we want to get high
and then it was just
four people just talking you know
something that you know there was no
hollywood no
no nothing
they pulled up because joey would he
stayed in a dump like this one i knew as
soon as he got in the car
he was a member of the church and he
came over and we sat and we spoke and he
was a vet and uh
he really he really inspired me you know
as a 25 year old kid to come back and uh
he was already in a war you know and
what the [ __ ] have i done at 25 but uh i
admire that and inspired me
he was with his girlfriend he's going
back to school you know it really
[ __ ] inspired the [ __ ] out of me how
some people come back and cry you know
and
this is this is this they don't accept
me
uh some people come back and just pick
their [ __ ] pants on you know i i
never went to the service but i always
i always have a soft spot for them
because it's something i wanted to do
again another one of my regrets
i would have loved to been able to say
that i served my country i served my
country a different way in prison like a
[ __ ] jerk-off
but uh
it's a great experience for pe i see
what it does for them for some people
you know some people don't take anything
from experiences
but if i was in a hole and i was 18 i
had no [ __ ] future and i didn't i
just was a hustler and a survivor and i
knew how to put pieces together
you know i didn't go for my uh
physical because i didn't want to get a
blood test i had no problem shooting
people and cursing [ __ ] out but
god forbid i gave her i was so shallow
at that age that i overlooked such a
life
over a blood test something that takes
60 seconds you know
that was really the only reason you
didn't go that's the real reason i had
nothing going on that if i would have
gone i would had some type of it would
have been the push i needed i was
pushing myself at that age so it wasn't
like uh i was just sitting there
watching mtv all [ __ ] day watching
videos
i was still out there doing my thing but
it's always been one of my listen man
if you're 18 and you join the service
you [ __ ] retire by the time you're
38. you know what that's like to be
walking around with 38 and getting
checks in the mail you go back to
college
you could do a thousand [ __ ] things
you know and i know that you put up with
a lot of [ __ ] but you put up a lot of
[ __ ] in life
if you're 18 and you go work in a
[ __ ] warehouse how much [ __ ] do you
put up with they give you 7.50 an hour
you got to be there on time maybe your
boss is angry [ __ ] passive he wants
to be a ballet star but he ended up in a
[ __ ] warehouse and now he takes that
on you every [ __ ] day what's the
difference what's the [ __ ] difference
when you see people
that uptight in their jobs that their
bosses and they push you that's because
that's not what they really want the
[ __ ] i hate that [ __ ] yeah when i used
to work when i used to be a [ __ ]
civilian and people come in tony's here
you know make believe you're working
[ __ ] yeah you know
i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] and i
understand what people go through on a
daily basis when they work you know
and it's so weird like you could tell
when somebody's kind of stuck
those days when i was young i would see
those people we talked about this last
week when you work and you see people
that are older than you and you're like
that's what i have to look forward to
being that
that's what i have to even if i stick
this out and learn this career and
i look forward to being that guy that
that's all you know he wants to yell at
me or [ __ ]
tell me that i didn't do the [ __ ]
boxes right or the orders i mean they
just come in to [ __ ] bring the energy
level down some bosses you know and then
they leave they just come in and spread
like a [ __ ] one of those chinese
people the mongolians that killed
everybody yeah they just come in slice
your head off and leave you know so
i think what it is is when you're 18 and
making that decision
tell someone telling me that i'm going
to be 38 and retired
i can't even imagine you can't imagine
we really can't imagine you you you know
i talk this [ __ ] here to you guys and
and i'm wrong for talking it because
give me [ __ ] 10 18 year olds and i'll
show you one of those 10 that thinks
about the future like really the future
really even looked past 30 because when
you're 18
25 seems like a failure
it seems like gonna turn me away and
it's not and it's really not it goes by
[ __ ] fast you know because you
graduate what when you're how were you
when you graduated college
22 or 21
yeah because you go in when you're 18 18
22 23 yeah
and for the last three years before i
met you what were you doing
why i met you at 23 yeah you basically
met me six months a year after i got out
of college
so i mean it's just it's uh
and i don't think that people who go
into the army are going in thinking oh i
get to retire in 20 years it's just what
they want to do what they want to do at
that time you're right but like my
cousin my cousins i have both of them
are in there and they grew up
like so poor like it was just like their
mom was working at mcdonald's
and it just it's just it was terrible
but they both went in
one of them is one of the guys that uh
refuels planes in the mid air and that's
[ __ ] cool he goes [ __ ] he just
went to japan and hawaii like he and but
then the other one who has a kid spent
time in okinawa and london
and now that she has the kid they're
paying her more and then now she's based
in like north carolina for most of the
year but every couple years she has to
go to afghanistan for a few months and
but she's air force so she's not doing
anything dangerous
well you're always doing something right
because there's a war you get uh i don't
know what the word is activated or
i don't want to sound like a [ __ ]
moment i am [ __ ] but it's uh
it's just amazing the people that
the people that inspire me sometimes
like i don't get inspired by [ __ ]
movie stars and all this [ __ ] i get
inspired by little people because it
takes me back
it takes me back it reminds me i love
being reminded
i love being reminded every [ __ ] day
of what life could be or what life used
to be like so it makes me work harder
people that push the pass back and i dip
into that
once a day whenever i'm feeling down you
know if i'm feeling down about something
i go you know what
i'll tell you how bad it could be i
could be waking up with a piece of [ __ ]
next to my face with no blanket
no people learn from that
no it keeps me [ __ ] honest man every
because it keeps me knowing
what could happen any minute this could
all this is just a [ __ ] you know
uh i think if you're real and you're
nice and you you you genuinely love
people for what they are i think that
even in bad times you survive
have you always been like that because i
mean
just speaking for me personally this is
the happiest i've ever been so i try not
to like it's not inactive i try not to
but i don't find myself thinking about a
couple of years ago like oh thank god
well you can't fake happiness right you
could laugh and giggle and then when you
go home you're in your four walls and
you're crying you know you can't fight
that's the worst
and i did plenty of that growing up i
did plenty of that when i was uh
trying to become a comedian
from the frustration you know when you
when you want something so bad and you
can't get help you know and you can't
then you figure it out
you go you know what i don't need no
[ __ ] help i'm gonna figure it out you
diagram your own [ __ ] directions you
know and that's why i always say the
power of the pen
diagram your own [ __ ] direction
diagram your own [ __ ] map this is
your map
you know when you get in your car you go
i'm gonna go to [ __ ]
you know whatever and you press the
address and it navigates you it tells
you i wish life was like that
and
it happens to you make your [ __ ] plan
where you make your map that this is
what i'm doing and nothing's gonna deter
me from this you know
uh i'm boring man i'm a
individual one at the end that comes to
it because i do what works for me and i
do it exactly the same way every day
because it works for me when i deviate
from what works for me that's what my
day goes to put
i know what's going to work for me and
uh it's funny i'm taking a voiceover
class that's awesome right i take a this
is the second week out of three you know
i signed with a voice over agent and i
didn't do too well
and i'm the type of guy that uh
if i don't do too well either i figure
it out which i went online and tried to
read
or i know that if i mimic somebody i go
see somebody do it i'll get better at
that job
so what and i don't know if maybe you
don't know yet maybe that's why i had
the in the class
but like you're you acted in the longest
yard and then they want you to do the
longest yard cartoon how is that
different like it seems like it'd be
similar well when you do a voice your
emotion has to come through your voice i
don't have my hands okay i don't have my
eyes i don't have uh my mouth i don't
have my mannerisms
so maybe the the cartoonist or the
whatever you call them yeah there's a
word for them animator animator uh could
do all that with me but my voice is what
gives that character emotion with
cartoons okay and it's so weird that
this is all falling in because now i
watch cartoons again
oh yeah
i've been watching peppa pig peppa pig
by the way is [ __ ] hysterical i don't
even know that one peppa pig is this
cartoon that replaced a bunch of [ __ ] on
nick at night
it's this [ __ ] pig with an english
accent
and it [ __ ] pissed mercy off for
about a month oh she didn't like it no
because she already knew what time these
things come out it was team umizoomi
comes on but now they've replaced the
whole nick at night network with [ __ ]
peppa pig and she snaps so every morning
i take mercy and i sit around my lap and
we watch i go to abc tv
and i watch all the abcs
i watch abc phonics i do the numbers
with her and then to break up the
monotony i do the alphabet by peppa pig
all the other kids videos uh beaver
whatever and abc.com
they all give you you know a is for
apple a
apple b is for ball ball ball ball c is
for cat kick cat
d is for dog they give you all these
[ __ ] words peppa pig's diner peppa
pig's abc just breaks it the [ __ ] open
she's talking about dinosaurs and
[ __ ] cat food like her words are
funnier and the pigs the daddy pig the
mommy pig i [ __ ] giggle every time i
watch the alphabet
but it's amazing how you uh
not
i just want to be good at it
you know i know that uh our lives go in
evolution i don't like my to be bored i
don't like being bored you know we had a
great time last week when we do two
podcasts outside we could have done them
in the office
we went against our [ __ ] green we
didn't play no music no video we just
went out there and had a talk we got
forced to do a podcast again yeah and it
was [ __ ] fantastic it taught me a lot
again i like switching [ __ ] up people
come to me and tell hey when are you
gonna do joy karate videos i'm not doing
them no more i might start doing joey
jiu jitsu videos pretty [ __ ] soon if
i lose some weight you know get on the
mat do some hip escapes and
[ __ ] and some [ __ ] judo
rolls by myself something just to show
people i'm [ __ ] up to but i still go
every day i'm going today the [ __ ]
jiu jitsu i'm going to 10 30 because i
thought i had a one
so i'm going up to 10th planet and i had
a great week last week jiu jitsu wise
because i went to class three times oh
wow
breathing i mean
it's gonna be so hard to smoke reefer
again in the mornings
because my breathing has improved when
you said i was like are you sure you're
definitely going to go back to because
you seem so happy i might take a few
hits at night just to help the [ __ ]
cause you know but uh i'm having fun
with the vapor you know the vapor
doesn't get me high after lunch time
after this morning rush i don't know
anything oh jesus
that's why are you high right now yeah
don't make me give you another one
[ __ ] you could use another vape
it's that time anyway it's monday
may 12th
i'm saying why are you looking at me at
that look because i'm high
um you get high you're not even an
edible you know what i'm saying so what
the that that's what they're there for
but if i brought another boy you'd be
[ __ ] crying too i don't want to i
didn't my waistline i didn't cry
um
it is kind of crazy because like for me
there were a bunch of editors who like
had been there for 20 years and they
don't okay oh [ __ ] and they didn't they
never learned new equipment or something
or they they they learn the bare minimum
so then they have a guy like me come in
and basically show them how to turn it
on
so it is kind of cool that that you have
to always evolve and always learn you
have to you have to i listen for 20
years people oh your voice is great you
greater voiceovers nobody ever [ __ ]
signed me for a voiceover
what did i do i did trip tank is it on
yeah time is the light on
let me see
[ __ ] did you [ __ ] it up
once i did trip tank at times just press
it
i'm supposed to let it i'm supposed to
listen to a burn let me see if i can get
it don't listen to nothing just
wrestling smoking don't listen to the
brain you want to hear it burn what's
someone listen to my [ __ ] as i
[ __ ] pop a fart god suck it press it
you press it
press it keep pressing and now i hit it
again
hey you didn't get nothing let your
finger off it for a minute let it refuel
press it again
two seconds hit it
slow slow not like a [ __ ] black [ __ ]
slow [ __ ] sucker
slow get the fumes in your lung that's a
way now let it sit in your throat
bust that [ __ ] vapor out there you go
you see what i'm saying who takes care
of you like your uncle joey [ __ ]
nobody
no i had it on tank i had i did the trip
tank
and i wanted to do more voiceovers and i
talked to a friend of mine
well that's what he does and i took him
out to breakfast and they asked him to
give me a shot and he right away he got
the ball going he threw me right to the
[ __ ] walls this guy was my commercial
agent 1997 also he was my first
commercial agent oh cool
so uh i signed with him across the board
i went to a couple auditions i didn't do
good
and you know me but i don't like doing
good especially when somebody works hard
for me i can't
you know especially those agents so
i checked around and i signed up for
this class you know that's what three
different directors uh casting directors
from disney [ __ ] like that oh that's so
cool if i get a little bit out of it if
i learn one [ __ ] thing it was worth
the [ __ ] 80 bucks or whatever you
know
it's monday 7 to 10 and hopefully i'll
get better at it you know and this is
why you do these little workshops and
[ __ ] you know i don't i don't i don't do
a workshop for life for somebody to hold
my hand
i go i get their interpretation of it
and then i do what i do right and we put
it all together you know but that's
funny that you think just because i did
a [ __ ] i do it all i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm trying to learn everything the
book will be out by december
i hooked up with that girl yeah she's so
nice she's great
uh you know i'm gonna do this book i'm
gonna put another cd out so this is
what's in the works right now i'm
starting to do all this the book is
probably uh a quarter gone man it's i've
really been putting some time into it i
think i'm gonna only do a couple [ __ ]
different uh
weeks this summer i'm going to san jose
i'm going to vegas but i'm going to
focus on that book so it's done by the
end of august nice so by september and
uh 12 basically and it's been a [ __ ]
like listen i didn't know how to rightly
all right six years ago i sat behind a
computer and and uh in hollywood when i
stopped doing blow and i started putting
a blog up every monday and if you look
at those blogs today like joey you're a
dummy i didn't even know how to write i
had no ideas i had forgotten grammar i'd
forgotten spelling i'd forgotten
everything i've been that that long
uh i i made the mistake that a lot of
young people do in hollywood when i
wasn't young they come to town they buy
a writing book and they think they're
writing books and they do the writing
for them you can read all the books you
want on writing unless you [ __ ] write
nothing's going to happen you got it
right it's like everything else you know
you could stay at home
and watch jiu jitsu videos unless i go
in there and get beat up for a year
you're never going to get nothing you
only get better at something when you
get beat up at something but the main
thing is you got to do it
if you don't do it then you're [ __ ]
dead you know and that's why i do all
these little [ __ ] things i do to keep
me sharp i'm 51 lee i'm supposed to be
losing my memory i'm supposed to be
losing all these [ __ ] things and i
accept them but i got to keep the areas
that are sharp [ __ ] sharp
you know when you cover michael j when
you play when you played the [ __ ]
whatever
the bulls in the 80s the 90s you didn't
cover michael jordan to say you're gonna
shut them down that's not gonna happen
what you do is cover the other guys four
tightly and let michael jordan run his
game
do you follow yeah the the
the backing behind it the mindset and
that's just what i'm doing i'm playing a
[ __ ] box four on me
so whatever i'm strong at i go it when
i'm weak at them i'm just gonna get rid
of now because i'm [ __ ] 51 but you
don't want no weaknesses
you want to keep writing and keep
[ __ ] you know you just want to keep
doing it brother
that's great no
it's not that i didn't think you could
do it but it's just it's uh
i know a lot of people who when they get
to your age if someone to take a take a
voiceover class they might say all those
stupid casting directors don't know what
they're doing i'm just gonna
keep to this or i'll eventually get it
so maybe they don't know what they're
doing but neither do i but if i could
take one quality from them oh no you're
doing the right thing i'm just saying
what they would have said quality from
them if i could take
one line from them that i learned
something
then i'll be
i'll be [ __ ] ready to rock you know
yeah if i could take one thing from them
and learn that's all that [ __ ]
matters man
that's what evolving is that's what you
keep moving you know
for the last
three weeks i took the kettlebells out
three days a week out of my thing
because i was i was just eating too much
so now i go to the y and i do the
epileptical
and i do the bag and i do the bicycle
one so we've loosened up my knee i try
to keep it
you know uh i i try to go to one drill
class with john evan
but then i also go to one [ __ ]
fighting class with salami so you can
beat the [ __ ] out of me at the tenth
plane
and i keep it all going because it keeps
my mind fresh
yeah you know i can't do the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] every week you know so
if you're bored with what you're doing
just switch up a little bit once in a
while for a few weeks just to throw some
whatever in there you know this more i
didn't have a protein shake this morning
to be honest with you i had a [ __ ]
egg and i had a a piece of [ __ ]
whatever how you call it a piece of fish
i had fish left over yeah with no toast
oh [ __ ] yeah just something different i
have a protein shake when i go home now
okay you know because i had two protein
shakes the other night back to back
the [ __ ] farts that i had blasting on
the way down the sand whatever were the
worst ever when you have two protein
when you have a protein shake
at the end of your night for to help you
whatever after you work out because i
had a
yeah
thursday night or friday night i went to
jiu jitsu beginning jiu-jitsu late and i
went home and instead of eating i had a
protein shake then i woke up the next
morning my flight was early so i had a
protein shake what that all that way and
whatever the [ __ ] the chemicals they put
in there when you eat healthy that what
comes out of your ass is horrible you
can eat 10 white castles and fart and
it's okay i can't imagine a one egg and
a fish fart that smells good though no i
had a fried egg i ate the yolk and then
i [ __ ] had a piece of salmon yeah
left over that part's going to kill
somebody so what but it's protein
enriched i love it i love it when people
aren't right when i have bad farts
addicted to something oh i love it i was
blasting them yesterday and yesterday
was coming out of my asses the pre-farts
right in the plane but the pre-shit [ __ ]
the last one before that's terrible
that's uh
that's why why are you talking about
[ __ ] where's it it's monday may 12th a
little something for my mother on
[ __ ] uh post mother's day
i played this yesterday for my mom i
really candle i couldn't get flowers
because the cats eat them
oh really
my buddy frankie balzano always calls me
and tells me tell me where your mother's
funeral science so i could drop flowers
for it's not the same you know
a little tony bennett we've been gone
for two [ __ ] long people
the live podcast two music ones
we're back it's monday the 12th get your
[ __ ] together
you used to do
with me what the [ __ ] we
nothing i uh
i've decided that i'm gonna i have to
learn spanish for paula's mom okay and
i'm the [ __ ] worst at languages what
you're doing for mercy is so cool
because like i just
i can memorize uh
like microphones microphone or other
words but the [ __ ] grammar and the
conjugating word and [ __ ] listen
don't worry about all that [ __ ]
what you need to do is i got the
pleasure for you got one day every day
for one hour you're gonna go and put on
telemundo that's it that's it for now
this goes in different i want you to
listen
okay i want you to listen i do notice
that i'll book you take a notebook okay
open it from scratch just write little
words down because a lot of english
words sound similar in spanish that just
checks around a little bit so you got
that so as long as you understand one
word from each sentence we're halfway
there
then we're gonna pick up two words
okay i'm gonna pick up three words but i
want you to listen
something we don't do anymore we don't
listen god gave your [ __ ] ears to
listen that's why i love podcasting i
like the ustream i like podcasting
because it forces you to listen
when i was growing up it was albums
richard pryor so you had to listen
you know now it's you get more video and
all that [ __ ] i like when people have to
listen
if you listen to people talk spanish
one hour a day that's seven hours a week
in the morning eight to nine even if you
put on the news put the news on you put
the news on because when they talk about
their book this that sports
now you got it beat
okay that's because now you got an
interest
now you start figuring out cinco acetos
zero oh [ __ ] okay oh [ __ ] because it's
an interest of yours yeah now we gotta
find some [ __ ] mexican jews that's
what we need to [ __ ] find i'm sure
they have them no they got them uh one
of the guys that went to war with some
mexican jew but that's
that's your first thing is listening
is listening because before you could
speak it you have to listen
you know it's funny uh
how much of our
uh
learning process
is from seeing other people oh yeah and
we're not imitating we're just learning
and putting what he's doing to the next
level
you know i love spending time with my
daughter and i love doing that [ __ ] with
the videos but when i take it to those
mommy and me classes
because i go with my wife to them
sometimes like we went to picture day
the other day
and i had a great time i just sit there
and watch
and i learned from them you know i
learned oh my god that's why you bring
kids around
you know and it's not that we're
imitating somebody's we're imitating and
that's where the art comes in is
we're doing it our own way
and then we figure out how to do it the
best way
you know
uh maverick came to the shows the other
day maverick is a kid that's listening
to the podcast since day one
uh he's a producer and he sent me a
bunch of shirts from uh
the show on a e with the beards you know
the dudes chuck guys doug dynasty
and then he came up to me shook my hand
we were at the bar in santa fe and he
goes you know man i really like
what's happened to lee
you could see where lee
has changed and come out of his shell in
many ways it's not because you're trying
to be joe diaz
it's because you saw different avenues
and i learned a lot from you
but i saw different avenues i saw what
sometimes you see what's important and
what's not important
because of what happened to me early on
in my life i got to see what was
important and what wasn't important i
didn't have time to learn it
i had to just [ __ ] erase [ __ ] like
this ain't gonna work you know
this is this is
and
i always knew that i could help other
people because a lot of people run
scared jesus christ do people run scared
geez and nobody was more scared or is
more scared than me nobody in the
morning when i wake up those things i
write on that's what i have to
want to go out there and stab a
[ __ ] i got to push the extreme
in the mornings nobody's more scared
than me
but you you you know you you see what
you could do without and that's what
i've always laughed at society about
what you could really do without and
still prosper and still be a human being
yeah you know what you could really do
with that and that's what i always try i
hope that's what people take
guess you know one thing you could do
without in your life [ __ ] fear
fear of anything or anybody because it
doesn't matter the worst thing they can
do is [ __ ] kill you
that's pretty bad that's the who gives a
[ __ ] but you die trying
you die trying and that's that's a
better feeling we got a call no well
that's a better feeling somebody kicking
you in the [ __ ] stomach are you
saying i can't do it
do you know what i'm saying that's the
worst that's the number one thing we
have to get rid of but then there's
little things like i drove for 10 years
without a [ __ ] license
you know what i'm saying why everybody's
running scared you know when they tell
you as soon as you move to la you gotta
change your license plates no you don't
no you don't you know what i'm saying
and even then it's like what i was
telling damon the other day on friday
things about flying
oh yeah
when you fly
if i pull up
and i see a [ __ ] line of people on
american airlines that from now that
[ __ ] and the first class line is open i
jump on that first class line
i mean i get scared and before you that
lady says hi you stick your [ __ ]
license in that machine
and you start working on your plane
thing by the time she comes over and
says to you're not first class go
jesus i'm so sorry
i didn't know i thought and what you're
going to tell you go back to the line no
you already stuck your license into the
[ __ ] machine and got the computer
paperwork going it's over okay she's not
gonna cancel and make it go back in line
they're gonna say this time will do it
next time don't do it again who gives a
[ __ ] about next time you won't next time
i come here you won't be at the counter
anyway geez we didn't tell them what
happened i think it was last monday
before the podcast we went to breakfast
and you started yelling at cops
oh yeah oh it was so scary i was driving
i was driving to breakfast and the cops
there was an accident cops pull people
tell them what the cops were in the
middle of the freaking street and it was
annoying it was causing traffic at rush
hour which is bad already but you roll
it down the window and you're like use
your brains [ __ ] use your [ __ ]
brains and i was trying to get as low as
possible it's a rush hour and you got
the car parked in the middle of the
[ __ ] street for some lady who got a
fender bender pull your [ __ ] car over
it's [ __ ] what time was it lee am i
like
8 30 in the [ __ ] morning how much
traffic is there in los angeles this is
[ __ ] that's not the first [ __ ] cop
that does it they do it all the time on
the highway on the highway to pull
somebody up because who gives a [ __ ] up
there in the hov lane it's [ __ ] 8 30.
get the license plate and send them in
the [ __ ] mail but you're going to
pull somebody over [ __ ] 10 after
eight to give a total on a [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out of here that's not being a cop
that's being a [ __ ] idiot you're
supposed to serve the community when you
pull over and lancashire because there's
a homeless guy taking his dick out and
two cars like that and i gotta go around
them that's not protecting the [ __ ]
community man you know there's a big
thing that like going on right now about
[ __ ] cops dying and hey i sympathize
with the families i sympathize with
everybody but you live by the sword you
[ __ ] die by the sword la police don't
[ __ ] shoot nobody in the leg man they
shoot people in this [ __ ] town they
shoot the kill they do oh [ __ ] read the
pair every day what they had to shoot a
guy who had a gun shoot him in the leg
shoot him in the leg two times and that
like they kill everybody oh jesus they
kill these cops kill [ __ ] everybody
so you live by the [ __ ] sword you die
by the [ __ ] sword some cop wasn't a
lightning got hit by a [ __ ] drunk
driver woman killed two weeks ago my
sympathies go out for the [ __ ] family
but karma's a [ __ ] just because
you got a [ __ ] badge don't mean you
could double park or do what the [ __ ]
you want to do you got to be a cop but
you also got to be a human [ __ ] being
when i grew up i was a bad person i did
some bad things
but thank god the cops i dealt with
were human beings
they came to me and said what happened
this is what happened you want to arrest
me for two kids throwing their [ __ ]
hands up
really over a parking spot take us
around the corner sit there with the cop
car with the lights on watch us fight it
out and then put us in the car and take
us [ __ ] home but these [ __ ]
now a ticket draw but then they wonder
why the jails are packed because they
forgot to be human beings the police
department is corporate now yeah it's
like everything [ __ ] else in our
lives everything has procedures this and
this this and this whatever be a [ __ ]
human being i pull you over i know who
the [ __ ] the speed and i know who has to
get to where the [ __ ] they go i know you
don't think you know when somebody's
[ __ ] playing you you [ __ ] know but
there's people that are just trying to
let and you pull them over and break
their [ __ ] balls
you follow me it's just you know so you
live by the [ __ ] sword you die by the
sword i've always said karma 101 is a
[ __ ] and i'm not happy about
that the people's [ __ ] lies i know
i'm gonna get backlash for saying this
[ __ ] but it's true you pull up to some
there's people who have mental health
issues
who just wake up one morning and get a
[ __ ] action stand in front of the
house and wave it around you know what
you shoot tear gas at that [ __ ]
you shoot them in the [ __ ] leg with a
22
and you take them to [ __ ] mental
health facility they don't see it like
that no more they come in they'll shoot
you [ __ ] dead maybe for you forgot
three days to take your medication
people forget to take that medication
all the [ __ ] time
so a guy gets they didn't shoot martin
lawrence when he was naked
and [ __ ] whatever you know yeah but
they'll shoot a [ __ ] this town
man and they wonder why they're getting
killed because karma's a [ __ ]
calm is a [ __ ] [ __ ] you see
that a lot more with animals like dogs
and stuff that always breaks what's
going on the last three years with these
people shooting [ __ ] dogs i don't
know shooting a [ __ ] dog yeah
shooting a [ __ ] dog you know what
comes back to you when you shoot a dog
you know what happens to your [ __ ]
[ __ ]
something terrible i hope you know
michael vick apologized to it but
michael vic lives in fear
michael vick lives in fear you ever kick
a cat or do something bad to an animal
with karma you have a gentle animal yeah
there's some animals out there looking
to bite i could see you know i was
sitting there a day yesterday if i'm at
the park and i see a dog going to bite
mercy i got to kick him in the [ __ ]
neck and i love animals but i got to
kick him in the neck it's either [ __ ]
i got to go for the jugular i just
posted that today you go for a [ __ ]
juggler what are you gonna do i'm gonna
hold him back how police i gotta kick
that [ __ ] dog in the throat he's
about to bite my [ __ ] daughter or my
[ __ ] son right were we supposed to
have a call yeah okay
what's up brother
hey what's going on kids you bad
[ __ ] i haven't had john for a
while and i just wanted to talk to you
about a few things that have been
bothering me lately
well well let's do it bro you got the
flaw my man danny b on the phone one of
the last [ __ ] uh
real savages from our society back in
jersey
a rare breed a very rare breed to say
the least buddy
last week i was uh talking to these guys
about the movie the thief how i watched
the end of it and i broke into tears
because
that's what i wanted to be in 1983
that's why i wanted to be in 1984 that's
why i wanted to be in 1985 i wanted to
be a thief and i wanted to shoot people
and it was so sad that here i am today
and i'm not a thief and i'm not shooting
people but that was the mindset i had
you know and
i've changed this so many ways i mean
danny you used to get a call every 10
days have you seen coco he robbed my
[ __ ] house that [ __ ] somebody
took you know it was everything
dude
one of the few that always had your back
you know everybody was a finger point
there until you went to hollywood now
they're like there he is there's coco i
grew up with him that's my boy thank you
yeah [ __ ] everybody thank you thank you
now you know why the way i am that's
[ __ ] facebook and [ __ ] they always
even when i moved even when i left new
jersey i was still getting blamed for
robberies
and it's funny danny
we changed
i'm sorry brother they do the same thing
to me too oh i know you and i are the
[ __ ] scapegoats
you and i are the scapegoats that they
don't even talk about no more because
they're embarrassed because we weren't
supposed to be around we were not
supposed to be around
and it's funny how uh you know danny
we've changed we used to you know we had
a funny conversation yesterday about
selling weed you and i how for 20 years
we sold everything and now that wheat is
legal we want to do something else what
the [ __ ] we should be selling weed now
now it's legal it was easy it was hard
before
well how about this beyonce
danny dean
uh heavy it's 30 grand it's 300 grams of
reefer
8 grams of protein and 2 grams of bloat
wrapped up in a bazooka
for that last [ __ ] edge [ __ ] your
[ __ ] uh energy drink and all that
[ __ ]
but you know what danny every time i see
you and i look in your eyes and i hug
you and
i i
you know we changed we have families now
we have a wife you know we don't stay up
all night we don't give a [ __ ] of what's
going on
but the one thing is we really didn't
change danny
you and i really didn't change
we could still [ __ ]
flip that switch in the middle of a
[ __ ] but we didn't change our values
danny
you never i'm from north bergen just
like you we never went out of our way to
be [ __ ] cool we just knew that when
we walked in the room you had to suck
our dick that's just the way it works
out in my life you know confidence yeah
i still do that i walk into the room i
don't give a [ __ ]
you know i want you to like me but if
you don't i don't give a [ __ ] you're not
gonna hurt my feelings you know i'd like
to get along with as many people as
possible but
you know what it's not the case so i
walk into a room like i own the place
you know and that's just me i've always
done that and same with you man no
matter where you were in life uh balls
on your feet you know broke whatever you
always walked around see it's not what
you have it's what they think you have
in life so you got to carry yourself
with confidence because if you do that
eventually [ __ ] comes your way i mean
you're a perfect example i'm a perfect
example and it's only a handful of guys
like us in that whole area cops that uh
i go back there i saw the crew in
january you know we did okay that's all
i'll say without pointing fingers and
saying go [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself
we did okay
it's funny how uh
i'm not a lot of the things i used to be
but i'm still
that core person and i'm proud of it i'm
pr i don't know you know last week two
weeks ago the owner of the clippers got
in trouble it's all over the news the
chick the [ __ ] dude
i like to see you know and everybody's
like in shock danny about that this they
can't believe they said it
for once i like to put cameras or tape
recorders on people's minds to see what
they really [ __ ] thought
you know to see what they really thought
and it's like i know
yeah buddy buddy i'm sorry no i'm just
you're right man i just i know when
people are looking at me i know deep
down what they're thinking i know they
can smile and i know what they're
[ __ ] thinking ninety percent of the
time i was everybody's got a bit of
prejudice than in one way or the other
you know what he said i you know i
wasn't there you weren't there i mean
i don't even know that i don't give a
[ __ ] but listen it's part of life it's
[ __ ] part of life you know people
always gonna have their opinions people
are gonna say this and that but
as far as the life ban i don't know if i
don't know if i if that was necessary
personally i think they got a little
carried away with the sanctions but
you got to watch what you say when
you're in position coco you don't have
to you can walk on the stage and tell
somebody to go suck your dick
and get away with it but then
danny if you put a tape recorder in my
house you're going to hear the same [ __ ]
you hear on the podcast
and the same with you the same with you
i call my kids honey you think i call
them sweetheart listen i'm a good time
but in my house i'm real just like i am
in life my kids know they know when
daddy's got a game on to stay the [ __ ]
away they know what i'm in a good mood
you know i
listen i am who i am we don't change
people don't they might get a little
better but we don't change you have your
same values you are always good people
you're always good people that got dealt
a pretty rough hand in life but
again look where you are now you're
traveling you got your little soldiers
everywhere just
happy that i've seen their faces they
love you i love that i love them
i've seen it i've seen it firsthand many
times and it's such and i'm so happy
when i see
listen you've always been funny to see
you on stage it's something i've seen my
whole life i you know i've just been on
you know but these guys when i see how
they embrace you that makes me happy
because you're getting the love that you
really never had
you know your mom loved you obviously
but you had a rough life and
but you know you never change you're
still who you are
except for
except for the flying jew and people
i've hand-picked that have come into my
life out here
i am surrounded with people that i see
them and i drive home and i go how do
these people live with themselves
because 80 of what they put out is just
[ __ ]
80
i tell you what i'm walking around i put
out 10 [ __ ] maybe i don't know about
something maybe i have no knowledge i'm
speaking [ __ ]
uh what i don't know what the word is uh
negligently about something but i'm not
claiming to be the smartest guy in the
world what you see is what you see i
don't even know how half these people in
l.a could live with themselves they must
cry themselves to sleep every night
praying and hoping nobody really sees
the real them
i don't give a [ __ ] i want people to see
the real me because if you don't get
something listen we grew up with some
[ __ ] up people
but i took little things from them
as [ __ ] up as mike ronnie is one of
the most [ __ ] up people i ever had
around my life but he came into my life
at the perfect time because he showed me
that he didn't give a [ __ ]
right and that nothing matters if you
don't give a [ __ ] nothing really changes
people get to know that you don't give a
[ __ ] and either the people that don't
give a [ __ ] come to you the people that
are worried about what people have to
say they stay clear it's like my comedy
career bro i don't get invited to do
nothing danny danny it's hilarious
and i sit back and i tell the flying jew
i'll call the flying jungle watch this
they're not gonna ask me or they're
gonna do this and danny it's hysterical
and i don't know and it's for many
reasons one because yeah i kidnapped the
[ __ ] and put him in the trunk of
a car that always scares certain people
uh two i you know i told some
[ __ ] here like people are still
mad at me in the industry because i went
to awake danny and somebody was there
who used to torture this person in their
real life and i raised my hand for this
person and told him to get the [ __ ] out
that's why people are mad at me because
i told the truth
well
the truth hurts brother man the truth
hurts i i'm so honest with you that it
hurts at times but it is the way it is
i'm not you know
people can't handle they can't handle
the truth they really know so true they
really [ __ ] can't these [ __ ] mutts
out here
you know they'll do [ __ ] to to look i i
mean i have so many people that come up
to me and hug me and it's like they're
all judases
i could feel the judas hug and i just
laugh
because i know that someday they're
gonna have to suck my dick like at the
end of uh war pigs when jesus jesus
laughing spreads his satan laughing
spreads his wings that's every time i
hear that line i'm not a big satan guy
but i like that [ __ ] line because at
the end you're gonna suck my [ __ ]
dick because if i know you're a judas
i'll play you along
i'll play you along i'll play that judas
ham and then it start you know what it
makes me think like these people are
undercover cops
they all live their life like undercover
[ __ ] cops because you don't know who
the [ __ ] they are
i'm so proud i went to jail i'm so proud
i try to be a comic i'm so proud i have
faults i'm so proud i used to pick my
face when i was cooked up to
to [ __ ] because i hated myself that's
why i got scars i hated myself but i'm
so proud that i am who the [ __ ] i am i
am so [ __ ] proud of that all these
books on parenting and all these [ __ ]
gentiles with their [ __ ] and their
kids and
you know what your kids grew up to be
[ __ ] holograms of a human [ __ ]
being they're gonna grow up to have a
goat tea a sinatra hat a [ __ ] prius a
[ __ ] chihuahua a [ __ ] tattoo a
starbucks and texting to their friends
about gluten that's what they're all
gonna [ __ ] be and they're proud with
themselves
you're killing me me i'd rather be me or
you or the flying [ __ ] jew salute the
flag [ __ ]
hey listen man you know what the worst
offense is a family my family especially
you know there's a handful of them you
know i feel how i feel about james and
greg but take that out of the equation
they're all haters you know i i my wife
you know they they they're jealous about
my wife because she comes from a rough
background pittsburgh pittsburgh uh
phillipsburg you know phillipsburg you
know it's a poor town and she's got the
big house her family is jealous
and i don't even have we have four
people that i in my that's all that
matters to me right here in this house
because that's all that really cares
that's all that really matters i have no
relationship with anybody in my family
other than what's in this house really
coco it's because they're envious why is
he how did he get out of this you know
what because i never took [ __ ] no for
an answer and i went to jail you know
what you're right i'm glad i went i'm
blessed that i went to jail these
[ __ ]
half of these [ __ ] belong in
jail for [ __ ] being [ __ ] for [ __ ]
they should all [ __ ] go to jail for
walking around and not being themselves
i think that's the biggest felony you
can be is being a [ __ ] fake that's
the biggest felony in life if i was a
cop i just arrest [ __ ] for
being fake [ __ ] man
it drives me crazy
you know what i love coco you know we
got this little uh kind of social club
whatever it's a nice little joint
thursday night you got all these
wannabes the real estate guys trying to
close people you know what i hate these
[ __ ] business guys that make [ __ ]
80 grand here and they walk around like
they're hot [ __ ] always talking business
always [ __ ] marketing there are the
fakest ones out there you know what you
got me going man you got me [ __ ] gone
it's monday
that's what i'm supposed to [ __ ] do
it's monday you can do anything today
stop being a [ __ ] fake rip that
[ __ ] goatee off your face and take
that sinatra hat and throw it away take
your dick out and go [ __ ] it i'm
slinging dick [ __ ] with anybody let the
pieces fall with the [ __ ] they made dawg
so that's what i do you know that's how
i can carry myself i don't really give a
[ __ ] you know i know who i am i know my
morals i know i'm the same guy that i
was years ago i was always kind-hearted
i just you know got wise and i and and i
kind of blocked out a lot of [ __ ] you
have to are you forget about it you have
to block it out i've lost more [ __ ]
friends the last two years that i've had
like but they're all friends from out
here which they come and [ __ ] go you
know you call these people then
and it's just hilarious to me it's just
uh
i see i hear like when i go to towns
people come up to me go hey man
is that i was telling lee last night
that people oh man that guy's really
cool and but i see you know you have to
see people what the [ __ ] they are these
people get confused by all the words
that come out of your mouth and not
people's actions they don't and that's
why i come on this podcast and i've
opened myself up i've opened it up to
let people know
these [ __ ] that are talking to you
they're talking to you from a million
dollar [ __ ] house
they're talking to you from a million
dollar house telling you about [ __ ]
life i'm telling you i still live in a
[ __ ] two bedroom that i rent and i'm
still and i love it because i'm still in
the [ __ ] heart of the game man i'm
the heart of the [ __ ] game
you know life's simpler that way we have
the big house and all that but we don't
need it me and my family would be just
as happy in a three-bedroom
anywhere usa as long as we're together
and i have to work still i i have it
good i have it better than most but i
have to work i have to wake up every day
just like you and you're probably one of
the hardest working comics out every
thursday on the [ __ ] road
tweeting doing this writing you go home
you do comedy i mean who does it harder
than you nobody i never want to i never
want to sit here and cry
i'm sick and tired i listen to america
cry and people cry everybody cries when
you have an opportunity to jump on well
i don't really want to work 70 hours i
have a family [ __ ] you and your [ __ ]
family you're not gonna have a [ __ ]
family if you don't [ __ ] work and go
out there well i want to be a good human
being i'm going to have time for life
what [ __ ] life what life what life
i don't have it you think that when i
got guys that work for me you know
during football baseball they help out
and then they want to go see their kids
play baseball on saturday you know
that's great and everything i haven't
had a saturday or a sunday to myself
since 19 since i was in jail that was it
and i've been working every saturday
sunday holidays
because i have to take care of mine so
when i got guys that cartoons i'd like
to go see my my kids well we'll go ahead
but just don't come [ __ ] back because
the day i could leave to go watch my kid
play
then you can know it you know what i'm
saying caller i don't know everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to [ __ ] die i say it all the [ __ ]
time every day i say that i don't know
how these [ __ ] people expect to do
anything in their [ __ ] lives
because everybody wants to do this this
and this and this but nobody wants to
jump into the [ __ ] waters
everybody wants to do it for my [ __ ]
and i see it all the time me and we talk
about it i'll call you and go lee
did you see what i'm doing i don't know
look at this guy we gave him this three
month nothing he hasn't done a [ __ ]
this is the same guy that'll call you
and cry or put well i don't have time to
build a computer all day but you got
time to [ __ ] cry you got time to live
your life how you've been living it
you know yeah and then you get mad at
other people
you you gotta work it bro you you've
done it you know nobody gave you jack
[ __ ] you know they've seen you on tv
they've seen you with adam sandler guess
what you still gotta work your ass off
you know that's [ __ ] that's that's
the way it is and danny
i wish they would have seen me before
adam sandler
i wish there was i wish there was a way
god could send me a clip of when i lived
with fernie in 1983
oh my god i miss him
fernie would work and i would leave his
house at 8 30 i would go to the
charities and i would get breakfast on
the arm
whatever it was six dollars three eggs
bacon toast and that would ask mr
charlie for a 20 hour advance
i wouldn't even pay for breakfast i'd go
can i get 20 a draw can you imagine that
going to eat breakfast and asking the
waiter to give you 20 bucks and putting
your [ __ ] so he would make me sign
the 20
the six dollar breakfast i give him a
ten dollar tip and i'd say i'll be back
here by five to give you 36
and with that 20 i had to go out and
figure it out so i had to take a number
one bus down downtown and go around the
old neighborhood and see who was dealing
drugs we left the window open you know
people have no [ __ ] idea
22 hillside i remember taking that bus
you know that's true too a lot of people
[ __ ]
oh man we can talk all day you can talk
about somebody's people a charity you
said that's a name that i saw mikey at
charlie a couple of years ago in hoboken
he owns a bunch of uh clubs down there i
don't know if you yeah no no i know all
about those guys but it's the [ __ ]
think of these people think of you had a
video of your life
from 1987 when i was bringing guns to
you and you were giving me powder back
to take back to colorado when i get to
your house
and we think about if these people
really saw that [ __ ] you know a lot of
people a lot of people get mad at me
danny and they go oh you bring people up
from your past and these kids you grew
up with that you're living in your past
you know why i do this you [ __ ] jerk
off to show you i'm not bullshitting you
[ __ ] how many other [ __ ]
podcast people could put people on from
their high school to tell you
[ __ ] at home how they really
how they really were in high school how
many how many of these [ __ ] dudes
that come on the podcast and act like
johnny banana could really call their
friends from high school and grammar
school and say tell these [ __ ]
what they don't know that's why i have
these [ __ ] savages on you [ __ ]
[ __ ] sorry about that you know
what man that's okay get biblical you
have every right it's your show no but
you're right they don't know they don't
know i i have a
footage stored footage in my mind of
many nights with you with russo clark
carrie my brother
and you're right it is a [ __ ] movie
you know what
if somebody was to [ __ ] film us all
night long from nine o'clock at night to
the two o'clock stage four o'clock in
the morning seven o'clock peeking out
the windows running around getting in
the camp going to new york robbing
somebody kind of you know it was [ __ ]
bizarre robbing somebody and coming
right back and partying
i remember joey [ __ ] what's the name
the chicarelli joey chicarelli you
[ __ ] i don't know where we called him
inspector gadget he looked like [ __ ]
inspector gadget this [ __ ]
[ __ ] would jump in the cab at
seven o'clock in the morning go rob
[ __ ] come back with 50 or 60 vials of
clock crack [ __ ] blood all over them
and you know they wanted it and they got
it but yeah i mean
i don't know how i get into chickarelli
though let me tell you something
crazy times man crazy times no they
wouldn't believe it they wouldn't
believe it and that's why i put you on
that's why i put timmy holloway on and
anybody else that called me and go i
want to come on i want to show you
people where i am now and where i was
then so you [ __ ] know you could
do this this is all [ __ ] that they
try to put fear in your hearts and you
can't turn your life [ __ ] oh how to turn
your life around send me 9.95 i'm like
go [ __ ] yourself you grab your balls you
get a knife you make a [ __ ] plan and
you get out there and do it [ __ ]
yeah here you go eight months 2004.
jamie's eight months pregnant i'm worth
millions of dollars life is going
[ __ ] smooth it's like i used to drive
around waiting for something bad to
happen you have to know you have to and
then then i [ __ ] i remember the
quarter the knock on the door april 8
2004 james schmidt upstairs i'm thinking
that they [ __ ] that he did something
with the rent the car i got him jamie's
like
the cops are at the door i'm like the
cops i said what the [ __ ] did he do hope
he didn't do anything with that car last
night
open up the door there's guns to my head
[ __ ] mess seven different agencies
there
[ __ ] stripped all the money out of my
account
you know uh lost everything everything
that i worked hard for for 10 years
after i got it did i give up no i didn't
give up i did my six months of house
arrest my probation i got back in the
game and i made my [ __ ] millions back
and i lost some along the way but i got
right back on my horse coke so all the
guys oh he made millions he made this
you know what and i paid the [ __ ]
price along the way too but ultimately
my ultimate reward was what i got now
and you never ever ever sold your soul
like these [ __ ]
that's the other thing what about that
dude that was tweeting us talking about
oh you're friends with danny he did time
what did you do you sucked the dick and
i'm supposed to take your word for
granted with that sperm breath get the
[ __ ] out of my face you [ __ ] [ __ ]
sucker oh dude not for nothing that guy
was a nut oh they're all nuts i get them
danny i get people [ __ ] hit me once a
day i wake up sometimes to emails that
are horrible when i laugh
because you thought about this all night
you thought about this all night to
write me to call me a fat [ __ ] felon
who gives i'm proud that i'm a [ __ ]
felon
you know when i say [ __ ] you how many
times and how many times were you in a
movie with bobby [ __ ] dinero
sylvester stallone adam said so how can
anybody have anything negative to say
about you you're the most no they have
to they have to listen it's in your
nature [ __ ] crazy it's in you and i
don't even give a [ __ ] about the
daenerys the long [ __ ] that doesn't make
me angry what makes me a [ __ ] man
danny is the journey and that's what
people understand
that's what people don't understand is
the journey and how you how you hold
yourself up as a [ __ ] man
you know what i never sold my soul you
know what i did my time they came to me
and said yeah if you roll on this guy an
ass man we'll take [ __ ] it bro i don't
even know that mentality i'll do my i'll
take my chance i didn't do nothing
there's no fingerprints the dude was in
the trunk of a car and i wasn't there
who gives a [ __ ] you wanna you wanna do
something to me dude in fact i i called
him last night i called vala last
message i love ken vela i really do i'm
sorry about that day but it just goes to
show you sometimes uh you know life
duplicates movies we make mistakes we
make mistakes
sometimes we all you know what though
but that's the thing dignity man i got
in trouble same with you i could have
rolled on people i could have took down
frank jumper and all of those [ __ ]
guys that they wanted me to roll on and
that knocked on the date [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that you know what if i didn't go to
prison
i would have been bad anyway so speaking
of prison what do we hear from gary
we don't hear nothing i've been getting
emails about gary i got an email about
gary once a week
well you know what we haven't had no
contact any of us i think the last
letter came in last uh
right around christmas time
he's got to finish his first uh sentence
which i think was another three and a
half years and
i don't know if they convicted him yet
on the other crime the last bank robbery
but doesn't look good for the home team
coke he's probably gonna and i think
that's where he wanted no that's what he
wanted to be yeah that's what he wants
to be i think that we wanted it more
than he did he came out he was
overwhelmed he saw what my i have
my cousin michael does okay and he was
like he felt out of place here he he
felt like i don't belong here he spent
20 years his whole adult life
he was never right in the head to begin
with so i feel that he ultimately he
wanted to because he kept saying this i
just want to go to the beach i'm like
was that your goal when you got out of
hell to go the first day he got out that
i saw him anyway he was telling me he
wanted to take down some [ __ ] uh drug
lord
break him out of a federal prison in
tennessee that there's a 30 million
dollar reward on them i'm like so
this guy's got all that money and they
pick you
you out of all the people that they can
approach in prison to break a guy so i'm
saying so what's the plan he goes well
he's he's on uh chemo so we're gonna
find out when his doctor hours are and
we're gonna intercept them i said so
we're gonna how are we gonna do this so
i'm just playing around so i know right
out the door of coke that he didn't so i
said let's go let's go get you a good
lunch because i figured that might be
his last so i kind of knew out the
daughter gary
he didn't have long for uh
you know his time
you know and uh what do you make it six
months if that i think that's about it
he made about six months how's baseball
season treating you
baseball you know what i had a good run
last week i got some madness slapped on
me it happens i had a bad run last week
we snapped out of it a little bit but
hit and miss it's been a tough playoffs
uh the second round's been better than
the first round first round was [ __ ]
crazy at dogs dogs and dogs but baseball
is baseball it's a long season
ups and down and i think we're like four
or five games over 500 for the year it's
not we're not lighting it up we're not
getting hurt but it's a series of runs
man it's just
it's not easy i'm dealing with a lot of
good guys now so
i'm not working but yeah baseball is
baseball we do well you know i'm [ __ ]
hoping to met to win a [ __ ] world
series here uh sometime soon but not
good
so what else is up with your brother are
they any good
huh are the meds any good
yes you know i'm always a mess i'm
[ __ ] i always remember you remember
jose cannotico yeah
with the thick glasses
yeah yeah tough kid yeah he uh he owed
me some loot for a long time i'm up at
hash wage [ __ ] getting some [ __ ]
booze and whatever milk or whatever and
i'm gone longer than i'm supposed to be
i [ __ ] come back my mother's like yes
canonical was just here
i'm like canonical he owes me the money
he goes she goes no she was gonna take
you to game six of the world series
so uh
yeah the the mets getting back to the
mets last time they did anything
productive was 86 but yeah speaking of
canonical yeah
he had tickets for game six and i just
wasn't home probably was uh small with
hash way in this [ __ ] game six
because of that but
the mets uh yankees man i had tori on my
show that was pretty cool had a chance
to talk to uh
mike torre he's a good old boy jason
abramo was pretty good friends with him
they came to the shows in florida they
brought uh they brought tori with them
oh really yeah nice guy very nice good
man very nice you know it was shocking
very very shocking how nice and genuine
he was and
you know i had a good time we got pretty
ham and i went out to uh that baseball
dinner that was a nice experience man if
anybody out there you like your baseball
anybody can buy a general ticket you go
to that baseball writers thing in new
york cocoa it's wonderful you get all
the celebrities there all the
baseball greats hank aaron made me cry
you know
it's just a nice time man but you know
i've always loved baseball coco always
my passion
you used to go to shea stadium and
[ __ ] yankee stadium and bring 20
people with you danny where can they
find you danny b wins still i don't even
know my [ __ ] number on twitter it's uh
danny wins for you or something like
that i don't know
and then uh
you offering any plans this week for
baseball yeah you know i just got my
regular stuff i'm kind of like you know
what coco i'm not really pushing much
right now i'm just doing my thing you
know and this is the time of year they
can go to my website
dannywinds4u.com check it out but i'm
not really pushing much i'm making some
changes that's why i'm in the process of
uh
of uh getting a website with like five
or six good handicappers and just kind
of being the pitch man for i'm getting
burped out with this i want to take a
different
i want to find some some time for myself
because i you know i'm getting up there
and uh so i'm thinking about networking
where i get a website and
i recruit five or six top guys in the
in the business and
you know i'm just just trying to do
something a little different something
to shake it up a little bit because i'm
a radio guy coke but i'm missing all of
this
[ __ ] internet [ __ ] guys are making
two or three hundred thousand dollars a
month
selling [ __ ] picks on internet it's
crazy we gotta figure something out i
love you [ __ ] we'll call talk
again
this week i just want to talk to you
about manhood and what the [ __ ] we've
put together and how you're one of the
few guys you jimmy valeno couple guys
you see these guys and they're still
[ __ ] men
i gotta come out here and deal with
these [ __ ]
you've been promising stay up stay with
me we'll go down in the stands have a
good time and that would be nice i
missed jimmy valen he was a stand-up guy
i mean
a lot of good people now i'm surrounded
with these [ __ ]
soul [ __ ] salesmen i love you
[ __ ] stay back thanks for having
me man always i just wanted to talk to
you i had a good time with you yesterday
i love you [ __ ]
yeah i got you bro give the wife and kid
a kiss and all that stuff we take care
thanks for having me my friends love you
make it a good day youtube buddy thank
you for the balls today
that's how the [ __ ] we do it lee
i'm just getting sick and tired of these
fake [ __ ] lee i'm so high i
picture that entire conversation like
you were in like an old italian
restaurant both wearing like wife
beaters and you had spaghetti meatballs
and it's flying the entire time [ __ ] it
jimmy
it's [ __ ] monday [ __ ]
i'm not gonna let you go out there half
[ __ ] up you gotta go out there with
some nuts tell these [ __ ] to
suck your dick you got a dream and it's
bigger than that [ __ ] dream let me
give some shout outs to my main man andy
huggy bear allen keep [ __ ] fighting
you bad [ __ ] noah's ark what
simon patel sandman i love you tracy
stay in the fight and billy anderson
you're a bad [ __ ] you understand
me talking about bad [ __ ]
i uh
went on stage the other day mixed the
matt brown fight and then i came out all
on
on twitter and then last night i got
home and it was on i taped it i taped it
yesterday and i watched it
two [ __ ] times
you know i'm gonna call matt brown today
he's gonna be on the show wednesday but
i'm going to try my hardest to get him
on because
i cried when i watched that i cried over
the patience i cried over the balls i
cried over his never say die [ __ ]
attitude
and when i see that i know that i'm on
to the right thing there's still people
that have that you're gonna have to
[ __ ] kill me to take me out it's like
me with comedy i don't give a [ __ ] no
more about these people i'm going for it
lee i'm going for it do it i'm done i'm
done with these [ __ ]
you know so that's it that's why today's
podcast little on the powerful side i'm
a little sick and tired
i know people at home sometimes you get
sick and tired of [ __ ] it's time to
[ __ ] pick it up
if these [ __ ] don't give you
the respect and the love you deserve you
know as a human being that you're a nice
person then you got to go back to basics
and take it from them and that's the
old-fashioned way so we're going for it
with the church i'm just letting you
[ __ ] know
let's start with our [ __ ] sponsor
wait wait we're talking about matt brown
here what the [ __ ]
was what the [ __ ] dude ah no that was
tremendous and the kid's silver my heart
goes out to him
because he took 80 [ __ ] knees to the
head and he never went down towards the
end you had to go down i mean that kid's
got a headache today
that kid can't think straight he's not
gonna think straight for a week it's a
shame but
silva put his heart out i never heard of
him before yeah yeah yeah he's been
around and he's one of these guys that
he's [ __ ] great i mean those liver
kicks and he kept getting them with him
those stomach kicks yeah he's great with
his [ __ ] legs he's jiu jitsu is great
it just wasn't great enough for matt
brown so
matt brown's a soldier but [ __ ] eric
silva i give him my heart too man that
was a great fight you know the ufc has
some [ __ ] up fights coming on but that
one was good that one was really [ __ ]
good
and it just uh now you know why i had
him on the podcast you know
let's talk about something that uh
i have a lot of fear in my daily life
and sometimes i get intimidated but
sometimes i get intimidated and i go
what the [ __ ] is wrong with me [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i bumped into matt brown
elevator once i never [ __ ] my pants that
much
his energy
is real like his energy is intense and
it leaks out of his pores
but i know people who are intense for
wrong reasons he's intense for all the
[ __ ] right reasons because the energy
goes somewhere it goes into his gloves
which gets punched into your [ __ ]
head you know what i'm saying a lot of
people have that weird energy but they
can't do nothing with it
yeah he lets it go and he boils it up at
the end he brought his [ __ ] twin boys
up there yeah i mean i love matt brown
and uh i thought he called out everybody
i thought he was going to call out
johnny hendricks his barber
you know this guy that guy [ __ ] yeah
when you you know when you're on that
much of a role you just like calling
[ __ ] out the ball but the guy
who trims his beat that's seven in a row
right seven in a row wow
what the [ __ ] is going on who's gonna
have to put the soundproofing in the
window but it's okay i didn't know they
have construction now every [ __ ]
place we go to early in the morning got
some [ __ ] dilemma now i got the
construction brothers next to me what
the [ __ ]
anyway uh i was happy i was having a
hard time sleeping on the road
i have a hard time i had a hard time
sleeping last week my sleep comes and
goes i'm tired in the daytime
sometimes i drink green tea at night and
it keeps me up even after i fall asleep
like i fall asleep from being tired
but the green tea the caffeine stays in
me and [ __ ] and uh
i don't even know what the [ __ ] i was
talking about so i got home yesterday
and i i wasn't jet lagged the [ __ ]
flight i flew back from santa fe from
was one of those wright brother planes
those little la bomba you were hating
oh my god i put my ipod on i closed my
eyes and put the [ __ ] hooded
sweatshirt over my head and i just cried
that's all i could do on those la bomba
flights because you think the [ __ ] uh
and something about sanjo santa fe and i
don't want to forget that i had a really
good time was the guy who read the place
zach
i deal with a lot of [ __ ] managers a
lot of people in the business this guy
was the top of his game
and when i tell you this young man was
at the top of his [ __ ] game
i don't know what his last name was i
just know him as zach i know he's half
spanish and
he's one of the elders on the tribe what
made him so great
his positiveness
his how good he was
as a manager reflected how good he was
as a as a leader i could see how people
respected him he was on the money with
us from a to z
there was no stone
anything we wanted we could have had i
mean anything anything
it was just a matter of time you know he
was that much the food i had in santa fe
new mexico
at that casino was so [ __ ] good
what do you have like authentic mexican
food from the south west like that part
because there's different styles of
mexican food by region okay especially
in this country there's the colorado
denver new mexico style with the green
chile there's the stuff you get here in
san diego and there's the stuff you eat
in mexico you know
uh but this uh you know in every every
when you go to chicago their tacos are
different you know the highest uh
concentration of mexican people are not
the southwest it's
above michigan really yeah michigan has
one of the highest concentrations of
mexican people when i do shows out there
latino fest and [ __ ] like that the food
was outrageous but none of the mexican
food i loved
because i was in colorado 15 years so
it's all green chili based
and i [ __ ] love it and then you have
the tex-mex you know that's i'm sorry
you have the tex-mex which will be
[ __ ] tearing down this [ __ ] week
oh [ __ ] with papacidos and all the
[ __ ] joints i got another buddy
taking us to a more authentic place
we're going to pop a doze we're going
down baby you know we won't have a time
to go to two weeks we just don't have
that much in us right and i'm not going
to be smoking wheat till saturday so the
appetite will not be there we're going
to get somebody to stand online for us
while we go get some edibles go get some
barbecue you'll be eating edibles from
midnight you'll be on probation animals
after this week you get your strike back
oh god after this monday you get your
strike back but what i was trying to say
was
with all the sleeping and all that [ __ ]
when i came home yesterday i was sitting
there a little confused i knew i had the
baby in the afternoon i know how to do
things with the family and i took an on
it turn around 180
and let me tell you something guys my
day was [ __ ] made
on it just keeps getting better and
better and better with their products i
went on their web page last night i mean
every time i go on their web page i
learn something
i read about something there's something
on that i could be using maybe it's not
the alpha brain maybe it's a digestive
enzymes maybe it's their kettlebells the
plain ones you don't even have to get
the other ones they have plain ones for
you and if you look at weight that it's
not a bad deal because you have to ship
them
on it has so many good things for you so
many healthy things for you you know my
knees hurt i take the strong bone you
know it has so many [ __ ] things for
you man go to honey.com go to honor.com
see what they have start with the alpha
brain you're having trouble and you're
running you're having trouble with jiu
jitsu you're having trouble with
basketball you're in the league you
don't think you have the endurance try
the shroom tech sport just try it go to
honor.com press what church church go to
honey.com or go to joeydiaz.net and go
to my box press church and then order
what the [ __ ] you want get 10 off you
put on the list and you're part of your
honor family try everything it's got a
money back guarantee go to honda.com
also dollar shave club did you see how
many things we got on twitter this week
that people could receive a dollar shave
clubs one guy got a pin for being there
for [ __ ] forever
let me tell you something dollar shave
club people
you do what the [ __ ] you want you want
to keep [ __ ] getting [ __ ] up razors
and all of it go go be my health i'm
trying to save you some getters i'm
trying to give you more money so you can
smoke reefer at the [ __ ] end of the
week i'm trying to save you a couple
[ __ ] dollars
one dollar six dollars and nine dollars
is all the packages cost and gets
delivered to your house no gas no
paperwork no nothing no phone calls
they'll send you an email to let you
know it's coming so you can look out for
it you get your razor sent to your house
whether you order one wipe charlie's or
the shaving buddy that's your
prerogative all i want you to do is try
the dollar shave club go to dollar shave
go to joydears.net go to dollar shave
club box press church then pick the
option you want one dollar gets you four
blades a month two it's uh i think it's
two three and four four so guys you
cannot [ __ ] lose i live with this
[ __ ] every [ __ ] day i love it i take
it on the road with me i love it the
handle is tough it's strong dollar shave
club go to joeydiaz.net go to dollar
shave club press what church and be a
part of this [ __ ] i get tweets every day
go on my wall you can look for yourself
people always thank you for the patch
and the [ __ ] letter and thank you for
dollar shave club well thank you for
hulu plus i ain't [ __ ] around either
when it comes to hulu plus two weeks for
free i'm talking about tremendous
[ __ ] movies i even had to write them
down because i can't believe it
sometimes from [ __ ] modern family i
mean just the dramas revenge the sleepy
hollow nashville castle chicago fire
[ __ ] kids show spongebob sam and cat
[ __ ] comedy modern family satellite
live south park the colbert report bob's
burgers reality you got shark tank
kitchen [ __ ] nightmares marvel's
agents of shield you got documentaries
you got [ __ ] sports you got latino
enough you got animation go go now
huluplus.com what are you pressing the
box first joey joey j-o-e-y you get
two-week stratus two weeks on the arm
two weeks for free try it out [ __ ]
sit there to your ass grows roots watch
everything tell me it's not worth 7.99 a
month after that and i'll tell you to
suck my dick and call me shorty i was
born in 1940. go to hulu plus right now
why [ __ ] around what's the [ __ ] coach
joey get two weeks on the arm you can
see everything all the shows i [ __ ]
told you all right also to my brothers
at escapepodtank.com
making the [ __ ] happen what they did
was they got the just tank
and they're gonna give you what the [ __ ]
they're gonna give you 250 okay just off
no 150 off to just the tank model go to
[ __ ]
let's go
calm go to their webpage read what they
have to offer you you got a question go
to the 1-800 line call jeremy direct
jeremy i'm thinking about this [ __ ]
isolation tank you know epsom salt what
talk the [ __ ] a guy you thought about
it you go float around with these tubs
with these people that whack off in
there and now you got to soak in epsom
salt and somebody's sperm sticks to your
[ __ ] neck you don't need that [ __ ] do
this in your house you have to get
[ __ ] in somebody's fungus
call jeremy 1-800 go to [ __ ] escape
by tank.com just for mentioning us
let me put it this way the tanks they
have a high quality tremendous now they
if you go to any other tank companies
and look what they got to offer you
you're going to save two to three grand
with a skateboard tank what they're
going to do for you today and every
[ __ ] day is when you call just look
at the just the tank mod they're going
to give you 150 off that alone if you
mention the church joey dears joey's
balls lee's [ __ ] the israeli flag
booyah you get 250 off they'll deliver
to your house it's gonna cost you extra
dough if you want them to come out and
[ __ ] install it you could you have
somebody locally installed whatever you
do go for a skatepark tank what i do
with you these are not sponsors i'm
trying to save you [ __ ] money
all right get your [ __ ] together escape
tank.com on it hulu [ __ ] plus
and uh
what's the
dollar shave i'm sorry i got a little
[ __ ] confused so what'd you learn
today you know what we learned today who
the [ __ ] are you who the [ __ ] are you 80
of you you [ __ ] bullshitting yourself
and trying to [ __ ] the [ __ ]
people around you by beginning i got a
tattoo look at me i'm cool what the [ __ ]
what is the word [ __ ] cool
when i was a kid it was a [ __ ] the
big thing was to be a [ __ ] man to
sling dick with three hands what's this
that's cool
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you
[ __ ] maggots is america get it
together cox suppers what else lee what
do you got
i mean why live with yourself if you're
[ __ ] phony how can you live with
yourself you gotta be scared they're
gonna find that i'm weak
i don't know that the [ __ ] just be
yourself they don't like attempt to suck
your dick who gives a [ __ ] that's the
church is all about telling people to
suck your dick and doing what the [ __ ]
you want to i'm not gonna show up here
with these guests
that are better than you i don't need
that [ __ ] nobody's [ __ ] better than
you people you people are better than
half these [ __ ] on these
podcasts trying to talk down to you oh
and meanwhile they sit in their [ __ ]
million dollar homes fanning their dicks
what the [ __ ] do they know about the
struggle what the [ __ ] do they know
about fear or [ __ ] or [ __ ] having
[ __ ] addictions or having problems
that's what puts us together as this
[ __ ] army that we are with a big dick
army of this [ __ ] country what lee
[ __ ] what'd you say [ __ ]
nothing i i i there's nothing i can
follow that up with big i like big dick
on me though you like that the big dick
army and it's not having a big dick it's
having a lot of [ __ ] heart and balls
and i'm saying like matt brown and silva
and [ __ ] what's up lee what are your
plans for today are you done for the day
no i got rick ramos tonight
uh what movies are you talking about i
don't know he changed it up i have to
call him we had a couple options um
but uh i saw a movie
over the weekend i saw the new neighbors
one what did you think brother it was
actually
funny it was actually pretty funny it's
not but it's we talk about it a lot
where it's funny
but it won't stand up i won't watch it
in five years but for that one for that
two hours in the movie theater yeah it
was pretty good listen you go to a movie
for it to take you away
that's why i don't i always tell you i
can't go to movies in the daytime
because i'm not taken away yeah i'm
focusing on i should be doing something
constructive i should movies for me like
i said i got two three hours and it
takes you away for two three hours the
best thing is when you go to a movie and
it's [ __ ] great yeah it's great you
forgot about why the [ __ ] you wanted the
worst thing is when a movie's so bad you
feel worse than you did when you went in
there yeah and that's what happens to me
[ __ ] six out of 10 times when i go to
[ __ ] movies i try to try to watch the
other [ __ ] you know what i'm saying but
what else did you do this week you saw
the girlfriend saw the girlfriend like
how what kind of cake did they give you
trace late chase that's what her mom's
late chase what it tastes like trace
later it's pretty good i've i haven't
had it that much but it's uh
it's kind of weird looking right
because it's like they soak it in milk i
don't know how they get the milk in
there it's like evaporated milk
evaporating milk you like but it was
pretty it's [ __ ] sweet but yeah it
was good
and it's uh
i can't tell you how important it is
for guys out there and what a difference
it makes
when
a girl's parents like you like i i like
how like how how important is it for you
because i'm sure where were terry's
parents cool with you from the beginning
or how how did that process go
listen man i've never been with a woman
that had parents like me from day one
i've never been like with the girl in
high school or parents like me yeah but
we're 18 16 at that age they really
don't know what you become you know they
really don't know uh
it's funny because the parents i had
when i got married
the first time yeah kathy
i could tell the mother liked me the
mother could see what i had gone through
on my face but the father didn't like me
i didn't blame him you know
that's his [ __ ] daughter
yeah
i was with them for two years
before he reacted to me the father you
know when he reacted to me
when i went to prison i got locked up
for kidnapping i was in jail for a few
days he came to see me he asked me what
happened i told him the truth
and he bailed me out
he put the bell up and he told me that
this is the things i had to do he helped
me a lot lately
i haven't smoked in the ray in 20 years
my old father-in-law i haven't spoken to
ray since uh
1991 23 years i'm gonna tell you
something there's not a week that goes
by i don't think about him
but i'm gonna tell you something else
there's not a week that goes by that he
doesn't think about me
that's how much we loved each other
after that initial you don't you never
know what it's going to take people to
react
yeah once i got locked up he watched me
like if i was one of his own sons
and i did become one of his own sons and
a couple weeks ago i uh we did a thing
about role models and i should have
brought him up because he really was
there for me
he was the one that he was a lieutenant
colonel in the air force
and he had worked with young men
and i could see his disappointment from
his own sons
his own sons didn't do what he wanted
them to do they became successful they
became roofers and whatnot
but he wanted them he was a polish
immigrant mm-hmm you know and he changed
he worked hard in the service to to
overcome that thing of you know changing
light bulbs being a pollock you know me
polox and
he was very proud of that and that pride
rubbed off on me
you know so he was a very proud polock
he never made jokes about beaulots
you know he was very proud and that
inspired me and i gotta tell you man
there's times i go on twitter or on
facebook or on google and i google him
and i don't have the balls to call just
because i know what went on between him
and his might his daughter
after we had the divorce and it would
break my heart i know things went on i
mean our divorce was so strong and so
painful that i know that's the part of
why they moved and left they didn't want
them to do it
they just wanted to retire and they just
wanted to be out of it you know
and uh someday i'll get the carrots to
call i'll get the balls to call them and
say thank you for what you did for me
those three years you uh
taught me that i could go back to school
that's what i got from that guy he
taught me that i could go back to school
which i never believed i was good enough
for college but he was like i was a
pollock and i went to the university of
buffalo and then i got my master's this
guy got his master's degree and he
didn't get he got it to prove a point
you know he knew four [ __ ] languages
jesus my ex-wife was born in germany he
was stationed in germany
so he was very proud of that and that
inspired me that always always
inspired me i still remember his face
when he was sitting on the other side of
visitation glass
i still remember
his face and what i expected him to
treat me like and what he treated me
like you know
and i'm really sorry that uh
i let him down
but
this is why i do this [ __ ] every day to
be better and this is what you do you
just get up and you [ __ ] someday
i get the balls and call him i can't
believe he's still alive i can't believe
ray's still alive and the mother i can't
believe they're still alive
and i feel bad about what happened
between him and uh you know i mean we
went to war man he was scared he was
[ __ ] scared he got involved in it
we were gonna shoot i mean it was bad
and uh he packed up the last time i saw
him
i had a hand on my his granddaughter i
used to have visitation i guess my my
ex-wife went away yeah and she was the
granddaughter was staying with him let
me tell you something
he was a guy that was in shape
he was always in shape but he always had
a couple drinks at night he always had a
couple gins on the rocks
and i never saw him drunk
that day when i handed him the baby i
saw him [ __ ] drunk because he
couldn't handle what was going on i was
his son man
i had become his son like i became a lot
of people's sons and uh
part of me let him down but the other
part of me then because i move forward
every day when i do this [ __ ] i think a
wreck you know
and uh maybe because of the power of the
church someday i'll [ __ ] be able to
call him so we'll end it with that i
love you [ __ ] me and lee austin
thursday friday saturday the 15th
through the 17th
and then lee and i again up at the ice
house may
27th it's a wednesday and may 28th i'm
in san diego at harrah's get your
tickets now and then after that the
summer's gonna be like
we're staying in we're gonna add some
flavor to the [ __ ] podcast wednesday
will be an american flag in here so get
ready to salute the flag before the
[ __ ] podcast we're going back to the
[ __ ] flag we're going back that's it
i love you guys don't forget uh we have
another podcast wednesday if you need
patches or t-shirts go to joydears.net
if you need you uh do radio t-shirts go
to leasehold.com
have a great day and i hope this podcast
helped you as much as it helped me today
i love you [ __ ] stay black
now that the show's over don't forget to
sign up for your free trial of hulu plus
who plus lets you binge on thousands of
fed shows anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast and get an extended free trial
of hulu plus when you go to huluplus.com
joey or go to joeydiaz.net and click on
the hulu plus banner and don't forget to
sign up for dollarshaveclub.com get high
quality razors sent to your door every
month